and with us now from Washington is Susan
page USA TODAY's Washington bureau chief
Susan good morning good morning let's
start with North Korea if as you heard
secretary mattis say the military
options would be catastrophic what
options does the administration have
here
well we've seen president Trump put a
lot of faith a lot of pressure on the
Chinese to act to rein in North Korea
not clear how willing China is willing
is to do that nor whether it would work
but that is seen as a more promising
option than military action which as we
as we just heard would put millions of
South Koreans at risk this isn't the
other big story this weekend Jared
Kushner and reports that he tried to set
up the secret back channel with the
Russians we have heard the president
defend at least his honor what does this
mean for Kushner going forward well I
think it raises serious problems for
Jared Kushner we see defense by on the
part of the White House of the
president's son-in-law but outside
experts describe this is quite an
extraordinary thing to propose using
Russian secret equipment to communicate
in a way that presumably was designed to
keep US intelligence agencies from
knowing what was going on I think we
have not heard the end of the story it
becomes part of this cloud of
investigation involving Russia that
continues to loom over the
administration Susan does the fact that
the former national security adviser
Michael Flynn was involved in this
back-channel negotiation does that make
it more problematic for the White House
and for Kushner yes I think it does
because we know that Michael in has
become a target a subject of the FBI
investigation and of the congressional
inquiries we know that he had contact
that seems inappropriate with the
Russians he was taking money not
reporting it so he is at the center of
this storm and the question is is he the
target are he is he that is he the
source that will flip to tell us more
about what was really going on in the
Trump administration and the the the
Trump campaign with regard to Russia
Susan I want to ask you about these
remarks of the German Chancellor Angela
Merkel made yesterday saying that she
said we Europeans must really take our
destiny into our own hands but basically
the post-world War two order is to some
extent over how significant is it in
your view to hear the Chancellor of
Germany say that
you know Anthony we've been looking at
this nine day trip the White House is
portrayed it as being very successful
but I think with the benefit of some
history this will be the most
significant development that comes out
of the president's first foreign trip
and that is this deterioration in the
architecture that has kept the peace
largely the u.s. European alliance NATO
now we have the German Chancellor saying
that no longer they can no longer rely
on at your pass to rely on itself this
is a fundamental shift in a
deterioration the role of the United
States and of the American president
when it comes to our traditional
alliance but Susan how much of this is
also Merkel trying to just speak to
people that she is trying to have
reelect her at this point well G is up
for reelection that is that is true and
all politics is local as we know but I
think that what she is saying is very
consistent with what we're also hearing
from the leaders of France and other
leaders in Europe that they were shaken
by what they heard and saw with
President Trump's visit on a variety of
issues including Russia and including
also the Paris climate Accords big
decision on that coming up this week
from the White House Susan page thank
you thank you